ja willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung
heute geht es nochmal um die Frage wie
man virtuelle Realität definieren kann
ich habe das schon gestern ab und zu
unternommen als Versuch das Ganze zu
definieren es ist gar nicht so leicht ne
dann wollen wir uns die Frage stellen
was könnte eine Ethik der Digitalität
sein oder genauer gesagt etik der
Virtualität wir hatten ja jetzt mit der
Definition die Ontologie abgeschlossen
und dann folgt als nächstes in unserem
Plan die Ethik
damit hängt vor allem die Frage zusammen
was virtuelle Handlungsräume sind das
wird heute im Zentrum stehen
Stichwort mit perversum
Horizon worlds
das Internet überhaupt
und Ausgehen von der Frage nach
virtuellen Handlungsräumen wollen wir
uns die Frage stellen was virtuelle
Handlung sind
das ist das Programm
das heißt wir wollen ausgehend von der
Bestimmung des virtuellen handlungsraums
bestimmen was virtuelle Handlungen sind
ich glaube so muss der WG natürlich
könnte man jetzt sagen Handlungsraum
setzt doch schon voraus zu bestimmen was
eine Handlung ist
aber ich möchte es vom Raum her
versuchen ein virtuellen Raum und dieser
Raum ist dann ein Handlungsraum und je
nachdem wie wir uns in diesem Raum
Verhalten
verändern wir auch diesen virtuellen
Raum wir werden uns ein paar Quellen
anschauen wir werden paar Videos
anschauen Werbevideo von Methan über das
wetterversum und wir werden eine kurze
Reportage uns anschauen über ein
Reporter der drei Tage lang im
Metaversum was das mit dem gemacht hat
das hat natürlich auch mit Wirkung auf
das physische das sind die Beispiele
Internet mit perversum aber auch
Computerspiele müssen wir diskutieren
als Formen virtueller Handlungsräumen
muss ich aber noch mal ein bisschen
zurückgreifen um das gestrige zu Ende zu
bringen physische und virtuelle Realität
wir hatten gesehen dass
physische Realität also materielles zum
Beispiel ein Papier Schein von einer
Banknote dass der genauso wie auch
technische Dinge
dass die unter bestimmten Bedingungen
geeigneten Bedingungen da gehen ganz
viele Faktoren mit rein dass die etwas
virtuelles konstituieren können
hier ist der Begriff der Konstitution
ganz wichtig line Radar Baker eine im
Jahr 2017 verstorbene amerikanische
Philosophie vor allem im Bereich der
Metaphysik und Ontologie hat hier eine
konstitutionstheorie entwickelt und sie
sagt meiner Finger von primary Kind ist
ins
circumstelling with Newcastle System
also neue kausale Kräfte kommen ins
Spiel wenn die Bedingungen geeignet sind
sie spricht also von kausalen Kräften
zum Beispiel mit Bezug auf Geldscheinen
ein bloßes pappblatt Papier hat noch
nicht die kausalen Kräfte wie sie ein
Geldschein hat was sind denn die
kausalen Kräfte eines Geldscheins ich
kann mir damit Dinge kaufen oder wenn
ich ganz viele von solchen Dingen aus
dem Fenstern schmeiße dann wird die
Menge verrückt das wird sie nicht wenn
ich bloß Konfetti oder sonstigen
Papiermüll aus dem Fenster schmeiße da
wird die Menge auch verrückt aber aus
anderen Gründen wenn ich ganz viele von
diesen Papieren mit diesen kausalen
Kräften aus dem Fenster werfe dann
tragen mich die Leute auf Händen
vielleicht wenn ich ganz viel von
anderen Papier aus dem Fenster werfe was
ich zum Beispiel Toiletten befindet dann
tragen sie mich nicht auf Händen es sei
denn es ist gerade Corona mal wieder
angezeigt also sie sehen das ist
ziemlich abhängig von Bedingungen das
soll aber nicht heißen dass es dadurch
relativ ist das möchte ich Ihnen noch
mal betonen also das etwas abhängig ist
virtuelles abhängig ist von
Rahmenbedingungen von Randbedingungen
heißt nicht dass das irgendwie nicht
existiert das ist ein bloß eine Fiktion
ist eine Simulation ist eine Illusion
Geld ist keine Fiktion das trifft es
nicht adäquat Geld hat Anteile von
Fiktionalität weil wir natürlich
zusprechungen vornehmen die nicht
eigentlich sind also ein Apfel hat
natürlich irgendwie mehr wert mehr mehr
wert ganz basal physisch physiologisch
als ein Stück Papier das ist völlig klar
wenn es ums harte unser Leben geht hart
auf hart kommt dann will ich natürlich
den Apfel haben und ich ein Stück Papier
anders sieht es aus wenn das Papier ein
Wert hat aber dieser Wert hängt ab von
äußeren Umständen die diesen Wert
konstituieren und das ist nicht schlimm
das ist sogar sehr häufig so sehr viele
Dinge werden konstituiert Lyn Baker
spricht davon dass eine unsere gesamte
Welt konstituiert wird die sagt sogar
auch Statuen Marmorstatuen sind
konstituiert der Marmor des Gestein
konstituiert die Statue da kommt man
natürlich was dazu die Form hinein aber
dennoch sind beide identisch und also
nicht identisch aber der Marmor
konstituiert die Marmor Statue genauso
konstituiert nach Link Baker ein Stück
Papier unter geeignet Umständen eine
Banknote mit einem Wert oder ein Stück
Stoff konstituiert unter geeignet
Umständen eine Stärke sie bringt hier
verschiedene Beispiele sie würde auch
sagen wenn man im materielle
teilchenatome konstituieren unter
geeigneten Umständen lebendig Organismen
ja
genauso sagt sie konstituiert unser
Körper und seine lebendiger Körper dank
Selbstbewusstsein unsere Person eine
Person also sie sagt Konstitution ist
eine Relation die perversiv ist die
überall gilt allen verschiedenen
Bereichen und soll hier jetzt nicht
diese perversive Dimension von
Konstitutionen interessieren und soll
nur der Fall interessieren wo es um
virtuelle Realität geht ich glaube wir
können diese konstitutionsrelation sehr
gut dafür verwenden obwohl den Baker
eben nicht von virtuelle Realität
spricht sie verwendet dieses Wort nicht
sie diskutiert nicht virtuelle Realität
am Beispiel oder anders gesagt sie
diskutiert nicht die
konstitutionstheorie am Beispiel
virtuelle Realität sie es gibt nur ein
Beispiel einmal das auch Geldscheine
eine Banknoten konstituiert werden aber
sie diskutiert das nicht als Fall von
virtueller Realität sie spricht jetzt
von konstituierenden Umständen sie
nennen sie g das kann ganz verschiedene
Umstände sein das sind Tatsachen je
nachdem wie man sieht es gibt eine
Prozesse sein es können auch Dinge sein
Relation sein die notwendige doch nicht
hinreichend für die Konstitution eine
bestimmten Entität F sind also die
Umstände könnten jetzt im Falle von Geld
oder von einer Bank wurde die entwährt
hat zum Beispiel sein die Zentralbank
eine funktionierende Demokratie muss
nicht vielleicht sein Geld gibt es auch
nicht funktionierende Demokratie als
eine zentrale Bank muss vielleicht auch
nicht unbedingt eine zentrale Bank sein
Denken sie mein Bitcoin hat ja auch ein
Wert muss also im intersubjektive
Verfahren gehen die Objektivität
ermöglichen diese Umstände gehen müssen
Objektivität erlauben die müssen
vermeiden helfen dass etwas je nach
Umstand sich wieder ändert dass ich die
Identität ändert und es muss noch ein F
geben was dann konstruiert wird also das
F muss unter geeignet Umständen selbst
geeignet sein um so etwas konstituiert
zu werden ich gebe ihnen Beispiel
sie können nicht alles zu Geld machen
oder alle Gegenstände so konstituieren
dass dabei was virtuelles rauskommt
nehmen wir mal jetzt hier als Beispiel
wie ich schon gesagt hatte in der
Zusammenfassung eingefrorenes Stück
Butter
machen sie mal ein buttergeld versuchen
Sie mal buttergeld zu konstituieren sie
haben ein gefrorenes Stück Butter
befindet sich ein Aggregatzustand fest
oder machen sie das anders mit einem
Stück Eis ein Eiswürfel genau dasselbe
vielleicht noch besser Stück Eiswürfel
Eiswürfel Geld
das sei jetzt der Gegenstand F wie kann
der jetzt konstituiert werden wie kann
jetzt auf dieser Basis die mein Wert
zugesprochen werden wenn er doch
verfließt Geld verfließt auch aber nicht
so dass die Basis des Geldes die
materielle verfließt das hat der Vorteil
der Banknote dass die ziemlich robust
ist ja so ein Euro Geldschein hält
einiges durch wenn man nicht gerade
zerschneidet aber der ist jetzt der
klettert nicht einfach so wie ein Stück
Küchenpapier tut
das heißt
wenn man jetzt ein Eiswürfel nehmen
würden dann könnte der kein objektiven
Wert konstituieren weil er einfach nicht
stabil genug wäre der würde zerfließen
beim nächsten übergehen wenn wir diesen
Eislöffel in dem Geldbeutel stecken die
Hosentasche wie ein Stück Geld oder wie
ein Banknote dann war es das dann ist
der Flossen das funktioniert so nicht er
ist also ein Möglichkeit
deswegen
weil hier natürlich auch die digitale
Technik diese Objektive Stabilität
leisten kann digitale Strukturen sind
robust durch ihre Null und ein Struktur
die sind auch objektiv die können
Dateien beliebig kopieren Sie ändern
nicht ihre Identität
weil sie so robust sind digitale
Strukturen eignen sie sich wunderbar um
virtuelle Gegenstände zu konzentrieren
natürlich gehen auch hier verschiedene
Bedingungen mit ein diese Umstände g bei
digitalobjekten zum Beispiel der
Programmcode wenn es im Internet sich
befindet die Struktur des Internets ganz
verschiedene Faktoren
und jetzt sagt Philipp 3 digital objects
Qualifying
unified stables structures with
attributes and relations to otherjects
and agents and usen interact with them
also digitale Objekte sind auch
virtuelle Gegenstände warum weil wir mit
ihnen interagieren können und sie sind
stabil und sie befinden sich in Relation
zu anderen Objekten muss man sich
natürlich fragen wie diese Relation zu
anderen Objekten zu verstehen ist ist es
zum Beispiel eine räumliche Relation in
den digitale Objekte zueinander stehen
ich glaube es nicht das sind andere
Relationen ja es sind Relationen es
verweisen zum Beispiel sind Relation der
Ähnlichkeit aber sicherlich nicht
räumliche Relationen ich gebe ihnen
Beispiel sie sind die Metaversum wir
werden nachher noch ein Beispiel sehen
sind die mit perversum sie sind mit
ihrem Avatar darin sie sind dort ein
digitalen Gegenstand
wie weit ist dieser digitale Gegenstand
von ihnen entfernt fünf Meter können sie
nicht sagen sie wissen gar nicht was der
Maßstab ist sie wissen nur dass sie in
objektiven Relationen sind sie können
die Relation zu sich messen Relation zu
ihrer Größe des Avatars aber nicht in
Metern oder überhaupt eigentlich nicht
in wirklich räumlichen Relation anderes
Beispiel sie sind im Computerspiel
Diablo 4 sie spielen das im Internet
oder sie spielen das Spiel RuneScape
vielleicht haben Sie schon mal gehört
das ist immer mein Beispiel da gibt es
einen virtuellen Gegenstand der ist sehr
selten das ist der blaue Partyhut der
hat einen Wert weil es so selten ist von
mehreren tausend Dollar und der ist
objektiv das ist wie eine Währung zu
verstehen gibt der wird durch die Server
wird der Objektiv konstituiert er er ist
immer an derselben Stelle oder ändert
nicht seine Art er wird nicht
vervielfältigt sonst kämpfen Inflation
sagen sie dann mal wie groß dieser Hut
ist der 20 cm groß ist befindet sich
drei Meter entfernt von dieser Bitte
können sie nicht sagen sie können nur
anhand des Spielmann aber das sind keine
wirklichen räumlichen Relationen es sind
Relation aber sie werden nicht unseren
physischen Relation Gerichte sind andere
relation
und genauso muss man noch dazu sagen
dass ich Raum und Zeit natürlich auch
ändern ja
digitale Objekte ich habe jetzt schon so
ein bisschen was gesagt die sind nicht
mehr wirklich räumlich vorliegen ein
digitales Objekt liegt nicht irgendwie
auf einem Tisch
es liegt vielleicht auf einem virtuellen
Tisch aber sie könnte es nicht mehr mit
unseren räumlichen Kategorien bestimmen
genauso Geld wo existieren Bitcoins ich
habe schon als Beispiel gebracht
vielleicht auf Ihre Festplatte aber
lokalisieren Sie es mal genau
Datenspuren sie können es nicht so
lokalisieren wie sie ein Gegenstand eine
Münze lokalisieren die auch am Tisch
liegt das ist nicht das ertäquate
Verhältnis zu Bitcoins auf einer
Festplatte und noch schwieriger wird
wenn es um Bankguthaben geht und online
Guthaben ist die bitte schon wo sind
bitteschön ihre 50 € auf dem Bankkonto
wo sind mit den räumlich auf einem
Server wo genau häufig werden die Daten
ja auch auf verschiedenen Servern
gespeichert sie werden vernetzt
miteinander sie werden gestiegelt die
räumliche Frage macht hier keinen Sinn
das in meinen Augen Kategorien fehlen
ähnlich wenn ich fragen würde ob
irgendwie ein ein geometrisches Dreieck
ein Geschmack hat ja das ist unrelevant
geschmacksprädikate treffen auf
geometrische Objekte nicht so und sofern
sie geometrisch sind ich kann natürlich
ein quadratischen Kuchen backen der hat
dann einen Geschmack aber ein Dreieck
als mathematisches Objekt hat kein
Geschmack genauso können Steine keine
Füße keine psychischen Eigenschaften
aufweisen seitdem ich bin ein paar
psychisch ja also sie sehen sie muss
immer aufpassen dass man nicht zu sehr
von virtuellen Objekten spricht in
Analogie zu physischen Dingen das ist
das hilft uns nicht sehr weiter wir
müssen es abstrakter fassen
und das möchte ich noch mal betonen
digitale Strukturen eignet sich aufgrund
ihrer anderen Raum Zeit Logik auf die
wir noch genau eingehen ganz besonders
dafür um virtuelle Realitäten zu
erzeugen als Umsatz die des F zu sein
was dann etwas konstruiert denn sie
garantieren eine inhärente
Verbindlichkeiten Objektivität digitale
Strukturen Dateien können Sie beliebig
vervielfältigen sie haben genau dieselbe
Größe 0.1 sie haben damit Objektivität
digitale Strukturen sind wunderbar dafür
geeignet Objektivität zu leisten zum
Beispiel bei Bitcoin proof of
workverfahren sie können das alles
wunderbar Objektiv auch prüfen durch
kryptoverfahren durch Checksummen und so
weiter und so fort das fällt uns in
physischen viel schwieriger so eine
Objektivität zu erzeugen
digitalobjekte sind wie ich sagte immer
über und überall mit sich identisch ein
digitales Buch was ich ja gestern als
virtuelles Buch bezeichnet hatte also
wenn sie ein Buch digitalisieren jetzt
aber im Sinne des der ocr-technik nicht
nur im Sinne des Abbilds es gibt zwei
Möglichkeiten das möchte ich noch
hinzufügen ein Buch zu digitalisieren
sie können es kennen dann machen Sie ein
Abbild von dem Buch dann haben Sie die
Seiten ursprünglich bewahrt kennen das
als Bild digitales Bild das ist kein
virtuelles
nach meinem Begriff es ist ein digitales
Abbild eine digitale Simulation eine
digitale Kopie
sie erhalten nur dann ein virtuelles
Objekt ein virtuelles Buch wenn Sie
dieses physische Buch mittels OCR
digitalisieren optical character
recognition weil sie dann nicht mehr
sich in abbildungsverhältnissen befinden
die Zeichen des digitalen Buches
referieren nicht auf die Zeichen des
analogen Buches sondern sie referieren
auf Bedeutung sie sind semantische
Relation dann und das bedingt dass sie
zum Beispiel sich lösen können von der
seitenfixierung wenn Sie ein Kindle
Lesegerät haben dann können Sie die
Schriftgröße verändern dann hat ein Buch
mal ein Kindle Buch plötzlich 100 Zeiten
wenn Sie die Schriftgröße vergrößern hat
plötzlich 300 Seiten wenn sie
verkleinern noch weiter hat nur 50
Seiten die Seiten Fixierung das ist eine
räumliche Fixierung die wird durch
digitale virtuelle Bücher aufgehoben und
da kommen dann neue eigen in den Spiel
und das zeige ich Ihnen gleich noch
anhand von verschiedenen Definitionen
fünf an der Zahl die in meinen Augen
virtuelle Realität Objektiv kriteriell
bestimmen lassen und das möchte mit
Ihnen natürlich auch diskutieren also
digitale Struktur nehmen uns Arbeit der
Verbindlichkeit ab die wir ansonsten
ganz aufwendig durch sozial und
theologische Regeln und Konvention
erzeugen müssen ja digitales hat eine
Objektivität oder eine Möglichkeit für
Objektivität die wir für virtuelle
Realität benötigen
die digitale Verbindlichkeit erleichtert
also virtuelle Realität so dass man von
einer digitalen priesterbillierten
Harmonie sprechen kann das ist natürlich
ein Bezug auf bleibt jetzt der immer
wieder auf sich gut eignet Stichwort
fensterlose Monaten denken Sie an die
w.a Headset Brillen die sind in meinen
Augen wunderbare Beispiele von
fensterlosen
simuliert jetzt ein durchblicken durch
die Brille weil man das Gegenüber dann
sieht man sieht in die Augen natürlich
nicht unmittelbar ist dann wieder
vermittelt aber warum fensterlose
fensterlose Monate bedeutet nach
Leibnitz nicht dass man für sich
irgendwie existiert in einer Blase eine
fensterlose Monate ist keine Blase die
kommen heute auch noch zu sprechen als
etwas was solipsistisch nur für sich
existiert seine fensterlose simuladen
sind obwohl sie nicht nach außen schauen
nach Leibnitz durch die prestabilierte
haben koordiniert sowie sei verschiedene
Uhren synchronisiert werden von einem
sagen über das ganze überblickenden
Lenker und genau so verhält es sich bei
wie April mit dem man im mittlerweile
auch wenn man da für sich eigentlich
eine eigene Welt hat wird das Ganze
koordiniert oder synchronisiert durch
die digitalen Struktur
durch den Programmen
denken sie schon ans Geld da fällt es
nur nicht so sehr auf auch Geld hat
immer einen technischen Aspekt oder
genauer gesagt vielleicht
technologischen Aspekt weil Geld auf
Technologie auch referiert Sie brauchen
um Geld zu realisieren brauchen sie eine
gewisse Technik man könnte auch genauso
statt Technologie
Medialität sagen ich verstehe Medien als
Form von Technik und Technik als Form
von Medien für mich sind diese beiden
Begriffe sehr sehr ähnlich also wir
brauchen damit wir zum Beispiel
Banknoten ein Wert zu sprechen können
Medien ein Medium das ist zum Beispiel
ein Blatt Papier
aber es ist eigentlich auch eine Technik
ist eine Technik es ist ein Hilfsmittel
und da haben wir ja wieder das Mittel
drin zu Erzeugung dieses Wertes und
diese Technik allein genügt natürlich
nicht sondern wir brauchen auch noch die
sozial unterologie wir brauchen
verfahren wir brauchen Banken wir
brauchen uns in der subjektive Einigung
das sind wiederum sozial unter logisch
ist also nur in diese Dopplung von
sozialontologie und Technologie oder
Medialität so meine These können wir
virtuelle Realität erzeugen
das ist jetzt natürlich nur eine sehr
generelle Beschreibung und jetzt möchte
ich wie lange schon angekündigt ihn
endlich mal Definition geben von dem was
ich unter virtuelle Realität verstehe
ob es überhaupt eine Definition gibt von
virtuelle Realität das wird bestritten
zum Beispiel sagen die Herausgeber des
Handbuchs Virtualität die Versuche einer
trennscharf Unterscheidung von realen
und virtuellen haben sich als nicht
operabel erwiesen
manche sprechen auch mit dem
verschwimmen von dem verschwimmen von
Virtualität und Realität es trifft aber
in meinen Augen nicht richtig das reale
und das virtuelle sind keine
gegenbegriffen
sondern das virtuelle spezifiziert nur
die Realität als eine bestimmte Form es
gibt materielle Realität zum Beispiel
hier den Stein da draußen den Baum das
ist materielle Realität es gibt
natürlich
artefizielle Artefakte die Flasche es
gibt mentale Realität sagen zumindest
viele unsere Gedanken unsere Gefühle
sind real und es gibt aber auch
virtuelle Realität wie zum Beispiel
werthafte Banknoten oder wie zum
Beispiel digitale Objekte in
Computerspielen
kann der Begriff der virtuellen Realität
überhaupt definiert werden hier
Herausgeber bestreiten das ist
bestreitet eigentlich fast jeder jeder
auf dem akademischen Markt behauptet
virtuelle Realität können wir nicht
definieren es ist zu konfus wir sind
dann aber letztendlich natürlich wieder
in der Unterlage confusion der Sie sich
sicherlich auch immer wieder befinden
während der Vorlesung aber so musste
sein jetzt will ich zumindest meine
Bedingung dafür geben oder Beziehung
dafür geben wie der Begriff der
Wirtschaft Realität definiert werden
muss um überhaupt drin scharf zu sein
ich glaube nämlich dass man ist wenn
Chance nicht unterscheiden sollte und
aufeinander beziehen soll also er muss
so definiert werden dass erstens er von
bloßes Simulation
Illusion und Fiktion
normativ Unterschieden ist normativ
heißt jetzt hier er hat eine wie es
wichtiger er ist mehr wert
Virtualität ist
ontologisch wertvoller als Simulationen
Illusion und Fiktion anders gesagt
virtuelle Realität ist nicht nur nur ist
eine Abwertung nicht nur eine Simulation
Illusion es wäre zu schwach und
natürlich Realität der Begriff muss so
bestimmt werden zu definiert werden dass
er auch ganz verschiedene medialen oder
technologische Phänomene wie Banknoten
digitale Währung und das Metaversum und
noch viele andere Dinge die dann noch
kommen werden sinnvoll bezogen werden
das müssen
das sind die zwei Grundbedingungen es
kann also nicht sein dass ich nur sage
virtuelle virtuelle Realität ist nur
dort der Fall wo wir es mit digitalen
Phänomen zu tun haben das sagen viele
das sagte z.B Michael Heim das sagt zum
Beispiel David chamas das wird auch
Germania sagen die drei Dinge die ich
gestern vorgestellt habe sind wir müssen
es schaffen virtuelle Realität auch vor
digitalen Phänomen
zum Beispiel eben auf Banken das sind
jetzt die zwei Bedingungen ich muss dazu
eines sagen ich habe ihn jetzt drei
neuere Denker präsentiert eine Denkerin
den Rutter Baker mit der
konstitutionstheorie es gibt natürlich
auch noch auf dem Markt andere Theorien
der virtuellen Realität die aus der
französischen Richtung kommen
zum Beispiel aus der
poststrukturalistischen Richtung
gelöst haben Sie vielleicht schon mal
gehört
da gibt es einige Theorien das liefere
ich ihn dann morgen nach wenn es um die
Ästhetik geht diese Thematisierung aus
der französischen
ausstrukturalistischen postmodernen
Debatte sind ihr ästhetisch zu verstehen
weil sie ganz stark mit der optischen
Bedeutung von Virtualität zu tun haben
wir haben ja gesehen es gibt zwei
Traditionen von Virtualität die ältere
auf die Antike zurückgehen die
Virtualität im Sinne der Kraft versteht
und die neuere die sie als Diskussion
versteht und in diesem Sinne der
Illusion die dann aber ästhetisch
interpretiert wird definieren häufig
französische neuere Philosophen wie du
löst Virtualität und das liefere ich
Ihnen morgen ab ich im Kontext der
Ontologie zu einem Kontext der Ästhetik
also morgen wollen wir hier auch ein
bisschen auf französische Philosophen
eingehen so und jetzt komme ich zu
Definition ich habe fünf
Definitionsversuche also fünf notwendige
Bestandteile die aber dann insgesamt
hinreichend sind für die Zuschreibung
von virtuelle Realität erstens
alternative künstliche theologische
Realisierbarkeit wichtig ist dir das
alternativ
ideologisch heißt da ist ein es wird ein
Zweck verfolgt und er wird realisiert
und zwar auf künstliche Weise künstlich
ist für mich jetzt deswegen ein guter
Begriff weil wir das Gut zusammenbringen
können mit der Begriffsgeschichte wo wir
gesehen hatten das Virtualität irgendwie
nicht unmittelbar direkt vorliegt
Virtualität hat häufig etwas verwickelt
ist was erst entwickelt werden muss wir
haben das gesehen anhand der das
analytischen Urteils alle Junggesellen
unverheiratet da ist natürlich auch im
Junggesellen des Prädikat unverheiratet
enthalten aber auf eine verwickelte
Weise nicht unmittelbar und das kann man
dann mit einigen weiteren Gedanken auch
als künstlich verstehen ich gewinne
erläuter virtuelle Realität bedeutet
dass etwa das muss man sich das fragen
was ist das etwas ein Gegenstand ein
Prozess seine eigenes ein Wert durch ein
verschiedenes Medium dass die
Alternative künstliche Realisierbarkeit
zum Beispiel durch die Digitalisierung
neu
bzw alternativ und künstlich realisiert
wird nicht nur simuliert wird und zwar
so dass seine ursprüngliche
Zweckbestimmung Kraft alternative
medialer Möglichkeiten dabei erhalten
bleiben
trifft es auf
digitale Währung zu kann man sich jetzt
fragen ob das der Fall ist ich glaube
schon wenn ich mich löse vom physischen
bankschein durch Bitcoins dann habe ich
ein neues Medium eingeführt nicht mehr
ein Stück Papier sondern die digitale
Technik und ich realisiere es so dass
Bitcoins sich ohne Probleme in Euro
umtauschen lassen können der Kurs mag
schwanken aber ich kann das Äquivalent
ich kann es in den anderen Wert
umrechnen ein Bitcoin Wert lässt sich in
Euro wert bestimmen genauso lässt sie
ein Euro wird im Bitcoin Objektiv
bestimmen senkt natürlich tagesaktuell
von den Märkten ab aber ich kann
Objektiv damit bezahlen und das machen
Leute wenn es wenn es ein Bitcoin
Automat gibt oder wenn es die
Möglichkeit mit Bitcoin zu bezahlen gibt
dann machen das Leute in Deutschland
nicht so häufig aber vielleicht
Kalifornien das funktioniert also die
Teleologie der Zweck der Zweckbestimmung
ist erhalten da ist eine Kraft und es
ist nicht nur eine Simulation
das schließt jetzt natürlich wie ich
sagte jede Form von bloßer Simulationen
Illusion aus aber ebenso bloße
technologische Verbesserungen wie etwa
den Übergang von pferdegetriebenen zu
motorisierten oder elektrifizierten
Antrieb warum weil die demselben
medialen Paradigma demselben
physikalischen Prinzip unterliegen
Virtualisierung heißt nicht nur
technologische Optimierung alles was
virtualisiert wird ist technologisch
optimiert aber nicht alles was
technologisch optimiert wird ist dadurch
gleich virtualisiert also das betraf ja
auch die Frage nach der Digitalisierung
nicht alles was wir digitalisiert haben
ist dadurch virtuell wenn ich ein Buch
nur scanne und nur bildhaftes digitales
Abbild macht dann habe ich keinen
virtuelles Buch dann habe ich ein wird
ein digitales Abbild eine Simulation nur
dann wenn ich es mit ocr-verfahren
behandle habe ich ein digitales
virtuelles Buch
die Alternative teleologische
Realisierbarkeit virtuelle Realität
impliziert deswegen Kreativität und
Künstlichkeit da kommen wir dann auch
morgen auf die Ästhetik natürlich zu
sprechen Kreativität weswegen man auch
mit einer Tugend lateinisch virtus der
Virtualisierung sprechen kann es ist
eine Kunst zu virtualisieren es genügt
nicht nur zu digitalisieren häufig
spricht man von dem was ich jetzt
Virtualisierung den Ärzten digitaler
Transformation nur dann bekommen wir
eine Transformation hin wenn wir es
virtualisieren nicht wenn wir es einfach
nur planlos digitalisieren ich kann
alles digitalisieren und vieles
digitalisieren nicht alles aber vieles
was gerade mit Informationen zu tun hat
aber es wird dadurch noch nicht virtuell
ja ich muss es richtig digitalisieren so
damit es die Funktion bewahrt und
zugleich in Rahmen eines neuen Mediums
neue Möglichkeiten hinzubekommen das
werde ich auch gleich noch mal sagen
deswegen erweist virtuelle Realität als
ein relativer Begriff bzw als
zweistellige Relation die nur gegenüber
einem zu virtualisierenden Phänomen
Bedeutung erlangt und es können wir
jetzt im gute analytischer Tradition
folgende Maßen formalisieren
zweistellige Relation heißt es gibt zwei
relatta die in eine Beziehung gesetzt
werden a und des V soll jetzt die
Relation der Virtualisierung bezeichnen
steht im Verhältnis zudem steht zudem
Verhältnis seine Virtualisierung oder a
virtualisiert B also zum Beispiel ein
mit OCR Verfahren behandelt es digitales
digitales Buch digitalisiertes Buch
steht zum physischen Buch im Verhältnis
seiner Virtualisierung ades mit
ocr-verfahren digitalisierte Buch
virtualisiert B das physische Buch
sofern ich eben ocr-verfahren darauf
angewendet haben man kann noch andere
Dinge diskutieren ja es ist nicht
trivial eine Digitalisierung vorzuziehen
und dann diskutieren die drüber
zweite zweites Kriterium zweite
notwendige Beziehung alternative
künstliche materiale Realisierbarkeit
bzw
endmaterialisierung das sind vielleicht
auch alles verschiedene Aspekte
derselben Sache virtuelle Realität
bedeutet dass die Alternative
Realisierung eines zwecks das war
Definitionskriterium 1 nicht mehr
physisch Raum zeitlich gebunden ist
sondern sich von der Lokalisierbarkeit
und Fixierung zunehmend lösen das mag
durchaus auch eine graduelle
Angelegenheit sein diese
Entmaterialisierung kann graduell
verstanden werden insofern etwa
Banknoten physisches Gold virtualisieren
und digitale Währung wird etwa Bitcoins
wiederum Banknoten so dass ihnen kein
physisches Medium wie Papier mehr
zugrunde liegt
also hier geht's jetzt um die
endmaterialisierung die man auch
vielleicht für geistigung nennen könnte
um an butterwerksbegriff der Virtualität
anzuknüpfen während der materielle wird
ein bestimmten ein bestimmtes Objekt
gefunden ist werden virtuelle Werte
subjektiv garantiert weil die Garantie
zentralisiert zum Beispiel durch eine
Zentralbank oder dezentral wie zum
Beispiel in Bitcoins durch proof of work
Verfahren realisiert werden kann
also hier ist jetzt wichtig der Aspekte
entmaterialisiert Virtualisierung
bedeutet sich vom physischen zu lösen
das kann aber auch über verschiedene
Stufen passieren ich kann vom Apfel
ausgehen der hat ein Nährwert dem
vielleicht gar nicht zugesprochen wird
der ist existenziell für uns überleben
sind wir die Fragen gibt es objektive
Werte an sich oder ist Werthaftigkeit
nicht immer schon irgendwie eine leichte
Form von Virtualisierung es muss ja mal
dahingestellt sein lassen natürlich kann
man sagen wer die kann man auch aufgrund
von Häufigkeit bemessen Gold gibt's
einfach viel seltener und Diamanten
gibt's auch viel seltener auf der Welt
als z.B Steinen aufgrund dieser
Seltenheit kann man durchaus auch ein
Wert zu sprechen ich möchte jetzt gar
nicht weiter ausführen mir geht's auch
gar nicht darum ob es jetzt
nur Werte gibt sondern ich setze einen
Wert an der Markt schon virtuell sein
ich kann schon latent virtuell sein ich
kann ihn aber weiter virtualisieren wie
geht's nur um die Relation der
virtualisierbarkeit und ich kann
natürlich ein Apfel Wert virtualisieren
Goldwert virtualisieren durch eine
Banknote das dann wiederum durch
Bitcoins usw mir geht's nur um die
Relation die Frage ist wirklich gibt es
Werte an sich natürliche wert
da wären Angebot Häufigkeit Seltenheit
physikalische Eigenschaften man kann
natürlich sagen ein Ding hat nie einen
Wert an sich sondern selbst ein Diamant
hat nur seinen Wert mit Blick auf uns
Menschen die wir diesen Wert schätzen
ich denke trotzdem dass man wenn man in
physikalisch bestimmt gute Gründe hat
ein Wert auch so zuzusprechen einfach
aufgrund der Seltenheit aufgrund der
besonderen
physikalischen Struktur kristallines
Strukturen Gold hat ganz besondere
Eigenschaften ein Apfel hat ein Nährwert
gut wenn es kein Wesen gibt was was ich
ernähren muss hat der Apfel dann noch
einen Mehrwert ja also sie merken es
wird ganz spannend so zu fragen aber das
interessiert mich nicht sondern nur die
Frage nach der Relation der
Realisierbarkeit
weiteres Kriterium alternative
künstliche median
Virtualität bedeutet dass die
endmaterialisierung der physischen
relativ durch einen Wechsel des Mediums
die in Materialisierung bedingt dass das
Medium zunehmend raumzeitlich flexibel
verwendet werden kann wie etwa durch die
Digitalisierung oder die Form des
Internets ein Stück Gold ist
physisch bedingt festgelegt wenn ich es
durch ein Geldschein virtualisiere werde
ich viel flexibler und ich wechsele das
Medium Gold ist Materie
bitcoin ist digital da findet ein
Wechsel des Mediums statt
viertens Verbindlichkeit Objektivität
und Stabilität virtuelle Realitäten sind
keine bloßen subjektiven Fiktionen oder
Konstruktionen sondern sind durch
Objektivität und intersubjektive Geltung
fundiert diese Objektivität und
Verbindlichkeit kann zum einen durch
Intersubjektivität und Institution
erzielt werden wird im Falle von
Banknoten gegenüber den physischen
fundierten Wert von Gold zum anderen
aber auch durch besonders stabile und
zuverlässige Medien wie die
Digitalisierung zu denken wäre aber auch
an einen virtuellen Desktop der den
herkömmlichen Schreibtisch die Ordnung
von Dokumenten und den Briefverkehr
medial alternativ realisiert das war
diese diese Sache die ich schon genannt
hatte
virtuelle Realität entsteht durch die
Vereinigung von Sozial-
damit besitzt aber virtuelle Realität
eine normative Dimension das ist eine
ganz wichtig es sind nicht nur
Simulation Normativität bedeutet das da
wiederum ein Wert drin ist als es ist
einfach meine These ist ein
virtualisierter Wert ist ontologisch
bedeutender werthafte als ein nicht
virtualisierter wird oder als ein
niederstufiger virtualisierter wert
obwohl sie natürlich
Objektiv auf dem Markt denselben Wert
haben aber
damit möchte ich einfach sagen es ist
nicht nur eine Simulation ich muss noch
genau auf diese normative Dimension
eingehen normative Dimension bedeutet
dass ich etwas an anderen Sache vorziehe
aufgrund von ontologischen Eigenschaften
in weitesten sind jetzt zum Beispiel
kann ich eben eine virtuelle Realität
einer blutsimulation vorziehen weil ich
sag eine Simulation ist ontologisch
nicht so bedeutend nicht so grundiert
wie eine virtuelle Realität und dieses
vorziehen scheint für mich normativ zu
sein und zum Schluss teleologische
Erweiterung Virtualisierung als
Alternative theologische Realisierung
das war das erste Kriterium physisch
gebundener Praktiken Gegenstände oder
Ereignisse bedeutet dass die
virtualisierte theologische Funktion
erhalten und durch den Wechsel des
Mediums
allerdings erlaubt die Änderung des
Mediums aufgrund seiner
endmaterialisierung und raumzeitlichen
Flexibilisierung neue Möglichkeiten in
ursprünglichen Zweck zu erweitern und
den neuen medial verwickelte Relation zu
setzen das passiert zum Beispiel bei
Digitalisierung sehr leicht zu denken
ist sie etwa wie schon mal gebracht
hatte an gedruckte Lexika
die durch Digitalisierung und Vernetzung
Internet wie zum Beispiel Wikipedia
auch die Integration von Suchalgorithmen
erlauben das heißt neue Medien werden
anwendbar sie können auf dem gedruckten
Druckhaus keine KI anwenden wenn Sie ihn
nicht digitalisieren oder virtualisiert
haben wie auch immer die brauchen da ein
neues Medium Virtualisierung bedeutet
keine mediale Publikation des
virtualisierten Phänomens
also keine bloße Abbildung im Digital
sondern eine Transformation die nicht
selten seine disruption die
herkömmlichen Technologie und Medien
führen das meint wieder diese normative
Dimension disruption gibt es nur dann
wenn das virtualisierte Dinge zu
virtualisierenden normativ überlegen ist
deswegen wird häufig das alte Medium
oder die alte Technologie dadurch völlig
abgelöst es gibt natürlich Phänomene
Retro
Liebhaberei das kennen sie am Beispiel
von Schallplatten an da gibt es jede
Menge Retro Restaurants wieder weil
einfach Schallplatten das wird uns zum
morgigen Thematik eines ästhetischen
Wert besitzen ja also eine Schallplatte
aufzulegen ist schon irgendwie was
besonderes ja eine Schallplatte vom
Staub durch Pusten zu befreien das ist
ein eine Zeremonie aber da würde ich
sagen das ist alles nur Tamtam mir
geht's um den Klang mir geht's nicht
darum nicht eine Platte aufzulegen das
ist alles äußerlich ja wenn wir nur auf
den Klang achten müssen wir eine CD
hören oder wir müssen eine Blut ist
können und wir müssen halt ein Medium
hören was die höchste betrat hat weil
das definitiv Definition und den besten
Klang produziert gibt eine riesen
Debatte ob jetzt die Schallplatte doch
ein besseren Klang hat weil sie analog
abgenommen wird die Experten sagen nein
aber da können sie mal gute Google ich
habe es gemacht ja aber spielen so viele
Fakt können auch beim Audio vielen
Genusses also audiophilie nennt man das
diese diese Audio vielen Menschen die
dann auch schauen zum Beispiel es gibt
Plattenspieler die in der Luft schweben
magnetisch damit sie nicht direkt mit
dem Boden in Verbindung stehen es gibt
also da kann man Geld ohne Ende ausgeben
also so ist natürlich jede Bereich ja
also das möchte ich nur sagen es geht
hier nicht um bloße Duplikation sondern
es geht um Transformation ja jetzt habe
ich ihn hier sehr viele
starke Thesen hier präsentiert und jetzt
möchte ich gerne mal sie hören ob sie
mir dazu stimmt oder ob sie vielleicht
auch ein Beispiel anführen können was
dadurch nicht betroffen ist
ja jetzt kommen wir nachdem wir die
definitorischen Fragen behandelt haben
endlich zur Ethik der virtuellen
Realität ich habe die mit anfragezeichen
für sie gibt es überhaupt Ethik der
virtuellen Realität macht es überhaupt
Sinn
hier sagt wieder der Pass also virtual
das not Intro used any special Liga
Problem
es gibt sagt er keine spezifische Ethik
des virtuell das ist alles im Rahmen von
allgemeineren Ethiken behandelbar
dennoch möchte ich jetzt das
Fragezeichen wegnehmen und dafür
argumentieren dass es eine Ethik der
virtuellen Realität gibt dazu müssen wir
uns einige Fragen stellen was sind
virtuelle Handlungsräume
was sind virtuelle Handlungen
inwiefern können wir diese virtuellen
Handlungen moralisch beurteilen und
normativ definieren unterscheidet sich
Ihre Bewertung von physischen Handlungen
was ist virtuelle Unmündigkeit was ist
virtuelle Mündigkeit und zum Schluss was
ist virtuelle Aufklärung
kann man sich natürlich auch alles
Fragen mit Bezug auf das digitalen
schreibt gerade ein Buch was ist
digitale Aufklärung aber das kann man
wunderbar auch generalisieren auf das
virtuell
das möchte ich mal anfangens auf
virtuelle Handlungsräume eingehen was
sind virtuelle Handlungsräume ich gebe
jetzt zwei Beispiele die sind vielleicht
nicht ganz klar voneinander zu
unterscheiden sondern hängt voneinander
ab zum einmal das Internet das ist jetzt
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
überraschend weil die meisten sagen
würden das Internet ist doch kein
Handlungsraum das ist ein
Kommunikationsmedium dann würde ich aber
sagen kommunizieren ist doch handeln
oder genau also viele würden das erstmal
bestreiten sie zum Glück nicht und das
ist auch gut so das zeigt dass die
philosophisch denken aber für viel ist
es erstmal tatsächlich überraschen kann
das Metall wäre so
das wird dir definitiv
explizit als virtuelle Handlungsraum
verkauft sage ich jetzt damit deutlich
schon die Kritik an das ökonomischen das
Internet ist ja an sich kein
ökonomisches Konstrukt ja wir haben
gesehen es kommt ursprünglich aus der
militärischen Forschung und aus der
Hochschulforschung Forschung und Militär
ging dann eine Einheit ein mittlerweile
ist das Internet alles oder nicht ja
alles gibt im Internet starke
kommerzielle Strukturen aber nicht nur
Internet gibt es auch viele Null
kommerzielle Strukturen denken Sie an
Wikipedia das ist frei von kommerziellen
interessens die freie Enzyklopädie im
doppelten Sinne frei im Sinne von
kostenlos und frei im idealen Sinne von
freier Meinungsäußerung wobei man da
durchaus auch Zweifel anbringen darf und
zum Schluss Computerspiele und jetzt
werden sie natürlich sagen wieso ist
Computerspielen Handel das ist doch nur
spielen ja aber auch spielen ist handeln
und im spielen
von Computerspielen sehen wir immer mehr
dass sofern es im Internet sich
vollzieht da muss man unterscheiden
spiele ich das Spiel alleine oder spiele
ich im Internet dass ich immer mehr auch
diese Realitäten
zeigen etwa dann wenn es um Währungen
geben digitale Währungen ich muss jetzt
nicht von eSports sprechen sondern ich
kann auch sprechen von Online
Rollenspielen wo digitale Objekte zu
finden sind und wo man mit diesen
Objekten auch umgeht also darin zeigt
sich durch das durchaus auch Virtualität
natürlich kann man sagen das Metaversum
ist doch eine Form des Internet ganz
klar aber es eben eine spezielle Form
die explizit als Handlungsraum ausgelegt
und verkauft wird
jetzt möchte ich erst auf den Raum der
Virtualität eingehen natürlich
Realitäten oder Gegenstände existieren
so meine These nicht den Raum und Zeit
zumindest nicht so wie physische
Gegenstände obwohl sie von Raum
zeitliches Strukturen oder Raum zeitlich
unterlegten Strukturen konstrukturiert
werden Beispiel online Guthaben
Gegenstände im Internet wo existieren
die Zahlen sind im Internet aber wo
können sie nicht sagen wir können keine
gps-koordinate angeben das kann ich von
dieser Flasche ich kann eine exakte
gps-koordinate angeben hier ist
das kann ich von dem blauen Partyhut im
mittlerweile fast nicht mehr gespielt
und online
multiplayer Rollenspiele RuneScape nicht
sagen ich kann keine gps-koordinate
angeben ich kann auch nicht sagen wie
lange diese Gegenstand dort schon
existiert vielleicht schon seitdem er
eben digital konstruiert wurde das kann
ich sagen er altert aber nicht der
unterliegt nicht der Zeit ist nichts
körperliches ja ich kann schon irgendwie
sein Beginn und Ende
zeitlich der terminieren das geht schon
eher aber auch nicht genauso wie jetzt
meine physischen Objekt virtuelle
Gegenstände sind durch eine super Leid
Fähigkeit und Reibungslosigkeit
miteinander verbunden Luciano solidi
spricht davon weil sie eben digital sind
zumindest die digital wir reden jetzt
vor allem vom digitalen
die sich der digitalen Technik verdammt
Geldscheine und Münzen sind natürlich
nicht so sehr reibungslos man die sind
ja physisch noch behandeln wir sprechen
jetzt vor allem vom digitalen virtuellen
ich glaube dass diese digitale
Reibungslosigkeit nicht nur eine
unwesentliche Eigenschaft des digitalen
virtuellen ist ein Wesensmerkmal
zum digitalen virtuellen spreche ich
jetzt und das ist auch in meinen Augen
des eigentlich virtuell ich hatte ja
gesagt Virtualität kann sich über
verschiedene Stufen
konstituieren ich kann von dem Apfel hin
zur Muschel hin zu Geldscheinen Banknote
hinzu online Guthaben hin zu Bitcoin und
da sehen wir ein endmaterialisierung und
die letzte Stufe und eine der letzten
zumindest scheint die digitale virtuelle
Realität ist
gehen wir mal auf die Zeit ein virtuelle
Realitäten Folgen keine sukzessiven
zeitlogik sind ihre Gegenstände sind
ubiquitärpräsent ich habe da mal von
Bubi Präsenz gesprochen was meine ich
damit die Ordnung der virtuellen
Realität ist nicht zeitlich sukzessiv zu
verstehen ihr logisch verletzt es geht
um logische Vernetzung nicht um
logisches Sukzession natürlich so
zitieren einige Dinge im virtuellen
digitalen Raum anderen aber diese
Sukzession scheint mir nicht so sehr
zeitlich zu verstehen sein sondern ihr
relational
Zeit der Digitalität oder auch der
virtuellen digitalen Realität entspricht
der zeitlosen C-Reihe John mccer
vielleicht haben Sie das schon mal
gehört ich komme gleich genauer drauf
ein die Zeit der Digitalität oder der
virtuellen Digitalität der digitalen
Virtualität ist keine chronologische
sondern eine logische oder relational
ich stelle mal die drei Zeitreihen vor
und mctagger ganz wichtig es gibt die A3
das ist die Reihe wo ich sagen kann
jetzt ist dieser Zeitpunkt der Fall hier
gibt's einen jetzt in dem ich mich
befinde von diesem jetzt aus im
Zeitstrahl ist der Zeitstrahl gibt es
etwas was vergangen ist das ist m und
was noch der Zukunft ist das kommt auf
mich zu sie müssen sich das so
vorstellen das oh kommt auf das end
zuläuft durch es durch oder ersetzt es
aus dem Ende wird oh aus dem gestrichen
oh wird irgendwann ein durchgezogen ist
dort an dem geht's die haben eine jetzt
Position eingenommen und die Zeit kommt
auf sie zu durchläuft sie findet Zukunft
irgendwie Vergangenheit das ist die ganz
starke subjektive Zeit die A3 und jetzt
die Beere das ist wenn sie sich
in ein Geschichtsbuch blicken ja da
sehen sie erst war das Ereignis dann das
sind das es ist sagen sie geben sich aus
der Zeit Erfahrung heraus und
überblicken die ganze Gedanken ohne dass
ich selbst ein Subjekt ist durchlaufen
sind das nicht die ihr Gesicht sie sagen
erst war das dann war das aber alles
vielleicht das interessiert sie nicht ob
es jetzt vergangen ist oder nicht
sondern sie sagen einfach mir geht's um
die zeitliche Ordnung das eine ist
früher als das andere relationale
da spielt das jetzt keine Rolle und dann
gibt's die zäherei
da interessieren sie gar nicht mehr dass
zeitliche ist wenn ihr das logische das
ist ganz schwierig zu verstehen wie die
zäherei genau zu verstehen ist da ist
der fehlt dieser Zeit Pfeil einfach die
liegen vor ihnen diese Zeit Punkte
eigentlich aber sie werden nicht mehr
zeitlich gerichtet gedacht sondern
einfach Release relational was auch
immer das heißt entsteht eben in einer
Relation zu oh und nicht entsteht hier
das ist eine Ordnung eine logische
Ordnung keine zeitliche Ordnung
das sagt aber die C-Reihe liegt der A
und der B-Reihe zugrunde das heißt damit
ich eine B-Reihe haben kann die eine
zeitliche Logik beinhaltet muss ich
schon die die ganz formale logische
relationierung dieser Ereignisse haben
darf nicht das wo hier hin tun
aber es ist keine zeitliche Logik und
jetzt kann man sich fragen wie verhalten
sich diese Zeit rein zum virtuellen
meine These ist das zumindest das
digitale virtuelle dass das nicht System
der zeitlichen Sukzession und der
physisch räumlichen Lokalisation zu
stehen ist sondern eher im Sinne der
Relation
ich kann sicherlich fragen
wann der blaue Partyhut im Online
Multiplayer Spiel RuneScape entstanden
ist aber das spielt eigentlich keine
Rolle für dieses virtuelle Objekt
zeitliche
Logik ist nicht so sehr relevant warum
weil es auch eine endmaterialisierung
ist nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel ein
physisches Lexikon und Wikipedia
Wikipedia steht nicht im Regal und
veraltet auch nicht nach 30 Jahren also
wir haben hier eine zeitliche
Flexibilisierung die Zeit in digitalen
virtuellen Raum die wird zu einem bloßen
Metadaten ich kann sagen wann Wikipedia
gegründet wurde aber die Zeit betrifft
nicht die Substanz eines Dingens das ist
nicht dem Verfall ein geheim gegeben wie
es physische Objekte sind deswegen
spielen bei physischen Objekten die die
Zeit einfach eine Stärke Rolle durch das
Vergehen durch den Wandel der blaue
Partyhut ist genau derselbe digital wir
zu seiner einführbar das heißt er ist
einfach an anderen zeitlogik unterworfen
beziehungsweise die Zeit spielt nicht
mit diese Rolle die sie bei einem
physischen Gegenstand spielt der
physische Raum wird im digitalen Raum zu
einer komplexen orientierungsrelation es
geht um Relationen aber nicht um
physische Reaktion körperlich es geht
nicht um drei oder vier Meter es geht
aber darum ob etwas so oder so vernetzt
ob etwas so mit diesem Gegenstand zu tun
hat oder nicht also da Räumlichkeit
haben wir logische relation
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
gibt es sowas wie einen virtuellen Raum
oder sogar einen virtuellen Ort Tobias
Hollister hat ein Buch geschrieben mit
dem Titel
über wissen sie von kybernetiks der
Navigator
er schreibt folgendes
während sich die Orte der Alltagswelt
angesichts der neuen Medien einer
Relativierung
möglicherweise sogar ein Neubestimmung
hinsichtlich ihrer lebenswirklichen
Bedeutung ausgesetzt sehen tritt in den
virtuellen Welt eine neue Orten zu Tage
deren Einordnung zwischen
illusionsfiktion und Wirklichkeit noch
nicht eindeutig geklärt ist als auch er
fragt sie zu Recht sind es nur
Illusionen oder ist da mehr Leid das
Öffnen eines Programmes in der Sprache
der Computer Nutzer ist nicht nur
metaphorisch gemeint es ist das Öffnen
eines Zugangs
bzw Englisch enter Betreten eines
Fensters Windows hin zu einem virtuellen
Arbeitsplatz
Desktop ist das ein virtueller
Arbeitsplatz fragen sie sich wenden Sie
die fünf Kriterien an
alternative Realisierbarkeit können Sie
mit virtuellen Arbeitsplatz das machen
was sie auch mit physischen Arbeitsplatz
machen können ja weil es sich um
Informationsverarbeitung handelt
schwieriger wird es dann bei einem
virtuellen Fitnessstudio habe ich gesagt
gestern sie können die handeln die
Gewichte nicht virtualisieren nicht ohne
weiteres dann müssen sie ziemlich viel
unternehmen also nicht alles kann eben
zur virtualisiert werden kommen neue
teleologische Eigenschaften
Möglichkeiten dazu natürlich beim
digitalen virtuellen Arbeitsplatz sie
können durchsuchen suchen Sie einfach
nur ein Dokument suchen sie mal im
Stapel der sich auf ihren physischen
schreibtischstapeln es ist gar nicht so
einfach da kommen neue Eigenschaften zu
deswegen glaube ich können wir von
virtuellen Arbeitsplätzen sprechen
diesen fünften Themen ein virtual
Arbeitsplatz ist nicht materiell
Verfahren und so weiter und so fort das
trifft alles zu der Titel Cyber places
vereint den Anspruch dieses Buches in
sich den Cyberspace als technisch
abstrakten virtuellen Raum aus der
Perspektive der ortsphänomenologie zu
begreifen und darin ortsphänomene zu
beschreiben ja entspricht der von
wiederverortung bezeichnet eine
Verortung von in der Alltagswelt gegeben
ab ortskonzepten im virtuellen das passt
dieses wiederverordnung weil wir gesehen
haben das virtuelle Realität eine
Relation ist etwas virtualisiert ja
etwas anderes und das haben wir hier
durch den Begriff der wiederverordnung
wie ich finde gut
abgebildet ja
neuverordnung
um neue Eigenschaften hinzu
das finde ich alles sehr plausibel also
man kann durchaus von virtuellen Orten
sprechen
auch wenn die nicht eben jetzt so
anzugeben sind wie
GPS-Koordinaten
gibt eine große Debatte ob es sowas gibt
aber ich finde das finde ich eine ganz
spannende Frage und jetzt kümmern uns
weiter Fragen bezogen auf das Internet
ist das Internet mehr als nur ein
konsumme Medium weil viele wird das
sagen inwiefern ist das Internet ein
virtueller Handlungsraum wie existieren
wir digital und virtuelle Kontakt
ich komme jetzt erst aufs Internet zu
sprechen möchte Ihnen zeigen dass wir es
als virtuellen Handlungsraum verstehen
können
Hub ADS Hubert 3 Fuß der übrigens auch
mal hier in München vorgetragen hat der
Sack folgendes schon vor einiger Zeit
und er kommt übrigens auch aus
Kalifornien also nicht ohne Grund
interessiert sich dieser Philosophie des
Internet die Internet ist nur just a new
technological innovation it is a new
type of technological innovation one
that brings out the very essence of
technology
es haben Leute schon über virtuelle
Realität gesagt denken sie als Bürger an
Michael hi der hat auch gesagt da kommt
was ganz neues warum weil da ganz
verschiedene Medien Leute zusammengefügt
wurde das Wesen der Technologie wird
hier
neu gefasst und jetzt bringt er aber
eine Kritik an den virtuellen
Handlungsraum und zwar am Beispiel von
Second Glide erkannte dieses Spiel when
we enter Cyber space and leave behind
emotional intuitiv
situations
of the reality first
of Germany commitment and
solutionsraum befinden heutzutage ist
das Wetter so wir schauen uns gleich
noch ein Video an dann verlieren wir den
Sinn für die Realitäten sind für unser
Leben wir sind nicht mehr verkörpert
dort sichtbar wir verlieren einfach viel
obwohl wir natürlich auch eine neue
Freiheit
freedom Freiheit von unserem
körperlichen Beschränkungen wir können
im neuen Form von Avataren dort auch
auftreten
mit dieser Körperlichkeit müssen ein
bisschen aufpassen denken sie zurück an
Apple Vision pro da wird unser Körper
zum Medium der Wirtschaft also wir
verlieren Sicherheit
den neuen Formen des metaphers nicht
unsere Körperlichkeit weil die ja selbst
integriert wird in die Wirtschaft also
so kann man sich nicht mehr sagen da
würde ich ihnen kritisieren er hat
natürlich vor Augen jemand der einem
Computermonitor sitzt und da irgendwie
so ein Avatar Stolz der an die dessen
einzige Körperlichkeit darin besteht aus
Klicks durchzuführen und die Maus ein
bisschen zu schwenken das kann man
sicherlich nicht als Körperlichkeit
bezeichnen aber sehen Sie es mal wenn
Sie diese Brille auf haben und ihren
ganzen Körper nutzen sie machen so so
und scrollen hoch sie führen Gesten aus
sie bewegen sich und ihre Bewegung wird
direkt virtuell umgesetzt da spielt ihr
Körper eine ganz andere Rolle der nehmen
sie sogar ihren Körper ganz an zwar weil
er virtuell ist eine als Schnittstelle
zur Virtualität dient also
ganz so körperkritisch würde ich das
nicht sehen
getan hat
ich möchte noch einen weiteren Begriff
nennen bevor wir in die wohlverdiente
Mittagspause übergehend den Begriff des
Online den finde ich ganz ganz toll
geprägt also online und live ne Luciano
floridi die vierte Revolution wieder
infosphäre unser Leben verändert er
bestimmt das Internet als
informationsfähre und ich als
Handlungsraum ich halte es für zu kurz
gegriffen das Internet nur als
Informationsmedium zu verstehen es ist
ein Handlungsraum
die digitale online-bild verschmilzt
weitet sich in mir aus in die analoge
offline Welt und verschmilzt wie dieses
jüngste Phänomen für Mädchen unter
diversen Bezeichnung wie bubiquitäres
Computing
umgebungsintelligenz das Internet der
Dinge oder Web augmented Singens die
Erweiterung der Dinge durch das Netz ich
verwende dafür liebe den Ausdruck online
live erfahren sie ist oder wird das
nächste Stadium die Entwicklung
Informationszeitalter sein wir leben
immer mehr online
Vermischung der Welt und physische und
virtuelle Welt und das heißt eben es ist
keine ersetzungsrelation
ja also es ist eine Kombination eine
Augmented Reality online ist Augmented
Reality nicht ersetzungsreaktion also
virtuelle Momente werden nahtlos
ziemlich die Werbung von Apple Vision
pro die wir gehen nahtlos in unsere
Alltagspraktiken mit ein
Google lens ein Beispiel oder andere
Dinge
Integration von KI in Prozesse
sie haben immer das Internet in der
Hosentasche ja sobald Sie das Smartphone
haben haben sie in der Regel Bezug zum
Internet
ja ich habe sie an der Arbeit habe ich
sogar das Internet an der Uhr hier also
und es ist die Frage der Zeit bis es
Internet irgendwo anders noch ist ja
vielleicht in ihren Augen ihren Ohren
das wird immer kleiner geschmeidiger ist
immer mehr integrierbar der Körper ist
immer mehr auch als Schnittstelle zum
Internet
sichtbar
die allmähliche informationalisier
Informatisierung von Artefakten und
ganze sozialer Umgebungen bedeutet dass
es schwer wird zu verstehen wie das
Leben im vor digitalen Zeitalter gewesen
sie sehen wir nehmen jetzt ein ganz
klaren Fokus auf digitalen in allem was
jetzt folgt betrachtende virtuelle
Realität nur noch als digitale virtuelle
Realität obwohl nicht alles Digitale
zugleich virtuell ist müssen eben auch
nochmal sagen in der nächsten Zukunft
wird der Unterschied zwischen Online und
Offline immer noch weiter verwischen und
dann ganz verschwinden viele reden so
als würde auch der Unterschied zwischen
virtuell und real,-
schon jetzt hat es beispielsweise wenig
Sinn zu fragen ob man online oder
offline sein wenn man beim Fahren den
Anweisung eines Navigationssystems
folgen das sind die Daten in Echtzeit
Aktualisieren der gleichen Frage wird
jemand nichts anzufangen wissen der
seine E-Mails abruft während er mit
einem fahrerlosen Auto unterwegs ist das
von einem GPS gesteuert
ja also finde ich sehr treffend
beschrieben das ist der Generation Z
unmöglich sein dürfte sich ein Leben
außerhalb der infosphäre vorzustellen
liegt dramatisch gesagt daran dass die
infosphäre nach und nach jede andere
Wirklichkeit aufsaugt okay die
Generation Z kam online zur Welt ist
jemand von ihnen in der Generation Z
würden Sie sich dazu zählen oder sind
sie noch Generationen ich gelte als
Generation why ich sollte das ganze
kritisch sehen alles hinterfragen warum
hier sagte jetzt dass die Generation
zählt sagen in einer faire lebt wo die
physische die analoge Welt gar nicht
mehr wirklich existiert zum aufgezogen
das ist eher so ersetzungsmodell Wasser
jetzt hier plötzlich bringt dabei fand
ich ja online live so schön weil es
diese Erweiterung anzeigt diese
Vermischung ja also man sollte das nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen sollte diese
Realität nicht gegeneinander ausspielen
was er meint ist vielleicht die
Selbstverständlichkeit mit der die Jungs
jüngere Generation mit digitalen Medien
vor allem im Internet zu recht kommen ja
und es ist ja ganz wichtig da eine ganze
natürliches Verhältnis dazu zählt
ja
das
bringt dir hier noch so ein bisschen das
wird die Welt verändern sagte um die
globale Gesellschaft entlang entstehende
oder Absicht vergrößende geographische
so zu ökonomische und kultureller Gräben
in eine Generation Z Plus und eine
Generation z-
unterteilen das heißt das Problem ist
nicht alle Menschen haben Zugang zu
dieser Infos für ja das ist ein Problem
globale Gerechtigkeit
kriegen wir das auf alle Gericht
übertragen
das setzt ja voraus dass alle Menschen
gleichen Internetzugang haben soll wird
das nicht hatte kann kein online und es
ist natürlich auf der Welt nicht der
Fall das heißt hier ist immer wieder
eine Parallele zum Thema
verteilungsgerichtlichkeit das würde
jetzt natürlich in die These von Maul
passt passen dass das virtuelle keine
eigenen neuen Probleme eröffnen so weit
bis hierhin können wir sagen alle diese
Probleme die hier auftauchen gibt es
auch schon anderen Hinsicht
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit geht es wenn es
um Nahrung geht wenn es um Grundgüter
geht und Grundbedürfnisse Befriedigung
geht und jetzt kann man eben sagen und
es ist glaube ich der Tenor von floridis
These des Internet ist zu einem
Grundbedürfnis geworden wie fließend
Wasser wie Strom die Wärme vielleicht
sogar wie Nahrung auf einer geistigen
virtuellen Ebene aber insofern ist auch
ein Grundbedürfnis vielleicht sogar ein
Grundrecht ist
ähm stellt es keine neuen Problem da
stellt es uns nicht von neue ethischen
Herausforderung ja dabei wollen wir uns
mal bewegen lassen für diese kurze
Sitzung in der nächst nächsten Teil
werden wir uns dann ganz konkret mit
einer möglichen Ethik des Internets
befassen und auch ganz konkrete
Beispiele von virtuellen Handlungsräumen
uns anschauen wie sie neue Dings als
Metapher für mir dann wünsche ich Ihnen
schöne Mittagspause bis gleich